have you had those times where you're
building your career or you're out there
doing world-class work or trying to do
world-class work or you're trying to
bring on your best game but you just
don't have the confidence we all go
through these Seasons I mean confidence
is like a roller coaster in many ways
you'll have weeks and months and even
maybe years where your confidence is
incredibly high and then we have these
seasons of lower confidence I'm sure
you've experienced those periods of time
those Cycles where your confidence is a
little lower and you might have a great
product you might have a great strategy
you might have a great team you might
have incredible opportunities but it all
begins with you and you if you do not
have that high level of confidence the
people around you don't feel it no one's
going to believe in your lofty Vision no
one is going to embrace and enroll in
your Mighty Mission if you don't
viscerally believe in it I mean no one's
going to believe in you unless you
believe in you and we really do have to
have the confidence to believe in
ourselves because a lot of time as a
leader a lot of time as a business
business Builder a lot of time as a
craftsperson we will be in the
wilderness we will have an idea for a
business or a product where the rest of
the world says that's impossible I mean
one of the things that world-class
producers all have a rare air levels of
confidence hey it's Evan Carmichael and
I make these videos because of my first
business I struggled to stay afloat I
quit my business partner and the thing
that kept me going was studying the
stories of famous entrepreneurs and
seeing how they struggled and seeing
what they had to overcome and listen to
their wisdom motivation gave me the
Courage the strength the belief to go
one more day and see my business through
and in all honesty I still need the
inspiration wisdom motivation today for
my business too so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to build
real confidence step by step
enjoy
avoid the energy vampires number two
avoid the toxic news and influences
number three avoid depletion through
distraction surround yourself with
confidence fuels remember that
ultimately life is incredibly short okay
and you have an opportunity to do
something great with your career and in
your life and a lot the victim postpones
being world class but people like you
and you wouldn't be watching this if you
didn't live what I'm speaking about
right now you have an opportunity and a
little window of audacity to use today
to go out there whether it's easy or
whether you're experiencing hard
conditions
to go out there and stand for the best
of human possibility and even when it's
difficult bring on inspirational
productivity you are going to walk into
walls you are going to face
cynicism and criticism and haters and
people who just don't get you because
the very job of a Visionary is to move
through the walls of being misunderstood
and you know this but your day is your
life in miniature as you live out the
rest of today so you craft your life
think about believing in yourself when
no one else believes in you remember the
idea that leadership is a lonely Sport
and do whatever it takes so within you
you maintain the confidence the
inspiration the energy the self Faith to
go out there in a world where people are
throwing rocks at you there are haters
there are cynics and the reality is most
people don't believe in Big Dreams most
people don't feel a lot of energy most
people are scared of a brave heroic
dream and we have to be coming from a
place from within where our I can is
larger than our I can you absolutely
absolutely must do the interior work
required where you have these fiery
levels of confidence where when the
world is saying you know what I dismiss
your vision or that is impossible you
have to be that lone Voice who goes no
you know what it is possible and just
watch me do it step number two is take
responsibility with Simon sinek no one
is born with self-confidence
zero
right every single one of us our
self-confidence was determined by how we
were raised the parents we had the
teachers we had the bosses we've had the
jobs we've had my sister worked for a
company for 17 years and her boss
destroyed her self-confidence she came
out of that job and she didn't realize
until she got into her new job how
afraid she was to make decisions because
of her boss and it took it took a while
for her to get her confidence back
um and so if somebody's insecure we have
to over and over and over again prove to
them
because we don't know where they came
from we don't know what kind of trouble
they got in before for being honest
right or what how they were raised we
don't know
and so we have to have to Total empathy
and just prove to them that that if they
make a mistake they're going to get
helped not hurt they're going to get
supported not yelled at and it the first
time they won't believe you they think
it's a game they think it's a con it's a
trick the second time maybe and we just
have to keep at it that every time I
used to have I used to have somebody on
my team who would regularly lie to me
right because she would rather lie to me
than tell me that she made a mistake
it was in and I could and if I saw the
lie I would ask so many questions to get
her to say to me I screwed up I'd be
like well this doesn't make sense
because I can't say you're lying to me
right I just say this doesn't make sense
this doesn't make sense if this adds up
to this then why is it that and she
would shoot the LIE would get bigger and
then she would yell at me about how I
don't trust her
and then at the end I have to be like
listen it clearly doesn't add up
I'm okay if it doesn't add up if you
made a mistake just tell me and I'm good
and we'll move on but when you deceive
me I'm going to ask you so many
questions to get to the truth
that it's going to get worse and worse
and worse I had to have that
conversation with her probably 50 times
before little cracks started to show
where she showed up to me once where one
number wasn't there and she looked at me
and said I made a mistake and I went
cool thanks
Alan mullaley puts it brilliantly he
says you you have a problem you are not
the problem
right so if something goes wrong we have
a problem but you are not the problem
and that's the point is we've too many
times told people that they're the
problem
so I think it's just going to take time
and patience and you have to do the hard
work of helping that person build up
their confidence again step number three
is stop faking your confidence with
Vanessa van Edwards I totally hear the
word fake and how that can set you up
for failure yeah so what do you do in a
situation because when I use the word
it's basically there are many times I
feel vulnerable or very many many times
I actually feel insecure yeah and I tell
myself it's okay so I don't judge myself
for it it's okay I like that but you
need to lead with confidence because no
one is going to gravitate to someone
that isn't confident especially in a
business environment or even if you're
dating for sure so I would say fake the
confidence but I understand the words or
what would you suggest someone oh I like
that situation so here's what I would
say
so another study
um what they did was they wanted to look
at anxiety and we're talking about
awkwardness I think that some very
similar kind of feelings in there are
anxious awkward
um shy
what this study did is they wanted to
know that exact question is what do you
do if you are anxious but you gotta fake
it right you've got you've got to find
confidence right they didn't use the
word fake it so what they realized was
that anxiety and anxiousness is a sister
emotion to excitement okay so when you
think about when you're anxious what
happens in your body you get little
butterflies in your stomach you start to
kind of sweat you get a little bit of
dry mouth you feel a little bit hot and
sweaty that's anxious like hard
palpitations now explain excitement to
me yeah exactly the same exactly yeah in
your body yeah anxiety and excitement
feel very similar the cousin or sister
emotion is there a way to reframe how
you're viewing your own anxiety
as potential excitement and here's what
they did they took people and they had
them come into the lab and they gave
them a task and the task was cruel in my
opinion what was it they had them Sing
Don't Stop Believing into a karaoke
machine so they were rated for their
accuracy of words accuracy of notes
accuracy of lyric like high pressure I
know okay
so I think about I forget the numbers
right so I had them sing this character
song but they had three different groups
okay the first group walked in sung the
song done control group second group
walked in and they had to say I'm
anxious
out loud and then sing
and the last group had to say I'm
excited
and then sing the song that's it no no
prep no mental nothing just saying those
words
of course the I'm excited group
outperformed out sung and actually
enjoyed the experience more and the
group that just said I'm anxious
this is I think such good news
it means that we are in control of how
we view our own anxiety our own
awkwardness
the opening line of this book which by
the way when I first submitted this book
to my publisher my whole introduction
was about you know science and data and
you know all these impressive things and
she's like Vanessa this isn't you
that's amazing she's like can you start
with something more vulnerable she's
like what's the thing that you're most
afraid of that readers are going to see
about this book and I'm like I'm afraid
that they're going to read this book and
think why would I learn about Charisma
from an awkward person she's like that's
exactly why they want to learn from you
so the opening line of the book is my
name is Vanessa and I'm a recovering
awkward person it's the most vulnerable
thing I could think of and instead of
for years in our business I hit it I hit
it under the guise of being an expert a
scientist a journalist
and the moment that I began to put my
awkwardness forward as a flip side where
I view my awkwardness as a very powerful
vulnerability
I do not view my awkwardness as a
liability anymore and I would say the
same thing if you're anxious or you're
nervous or you're lacking confidence
what is the flip side of that is it that
your anxiousness could be excitement use
that adrenaline is it that your
awkwardness could be a real
vulnerability to find other fellow
recovering awkward people right that was
why this book did well I think it was
that opening line that was why in my
videos I decided to put my awkwardness
forward it's the same thing I don't want
you to fake it till you make it I want
you to show up anxious and awkward and
learn how to use it also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there Step number four is love yourself
more with Lisa billu how can I make my
confidence and self-love more consistent
some days I love myself so much but then
the next day I hate myself more than my
worst enemy how can I love the woman
that I am all the time wow that's um
it's extremely vulnerable for you to say
and thank you for being so open and
honest about that because saying that
you can love yourself and hate yourself
isn't easy to say out loud and so I
think I just want to acknowledge the
beauty that you're able to actually
admit that so
um
quote that I love that comes to mind
that I'm obsessed with you probably
heard before and some people just use it
but like I really was like this is so
powerful
this too shall pass
this too shall pass meaning nothing is
permanent
nothing is always nothing is all the
time and so even in this question I
worry that you're just going to set
yourself up for failure because in those
moments where you don't feel like you
actually love yourself where maybe you
are criticizing yourself the only thing
I can say is saying this too shall pass
is to remind yourself they're not always
going to feel like that because if you
stay if you really do think it now
you've got one other thing you have to
overcome you're already beating yourself
up and now you're beating yourself up
over the fact that you can't let go of
the fact that you're judging yourself
that made any sense at all
so
it is going to be very important for you
for to remind yourself that whatever
stage you are now isn't going to be a
permanent State and so now we go okay if
it's not going to be a permanent State
how do I in those moments where I don't
feel like I love myself use the word
hate so I'm actually just going to say
that because you used it when I hate
myself
what can I do so that I can recognize
I'm not going to stay here because it
doesn't feel good right
and so that's the thing is that don't
judge yourself don't go oh my God here I
am again I can't believe I'm freaking
hating on myself oh my God I'm so
terrible when are you just
hey and it didn't help so that's where I
would say I was like okay I hate myself
okay in fact here it is Lisa you're back
here again it's okay you're hating
yourself it's okay Lisa we know you
we've got you and I would even talk to
myself like that see I'm even rubbing my
hands it's like we've got you this it's
okay now just go through why you hate
yourself like I really do do this
because once you actually just look at
the Roar of why you're saying you hate
yourself
it really does allow you to see the
truth of it right instead of going oh my
God you're so this and you're so that
it's like I hate myself right now
because
like actually say because
and then say
is this actually something I find of
value so what I mean by that is I used
to without realizing it I would walk by
the mirror
no it became a habit I would walk by the
room and I've got your thighs are hit oh
God your nose and that was it I
literally would consistently just keep
saying oh God this all got that so first
of all I didn't even recognize I was
doing it so in fact let me that's where
you need to start recognize the moments
where you are hating on yourself and so
once I started to do that once I said oh
wow how many times do I do that to
myself because I didn't even realize I
didn't even realize I was saying that to
myself so that was the first thing
acknowledge when you're hating on
yourself
oh man I'm doing that like every time I
walk past the mirror I'm always
criticizing myself okay instead of
judging myself for It Go these are the
moments oh every time I walk past the
mirror I clearly I'm always hating on
myself so I've got choices do I either
not to walk in front of the mirror
that's very possible
do I practice saying
damn you're fine whatever weight you
want to use that's what every time oh my
God that was so funny I couldn't believe
you I said that out loud but imagine
right like that's how I would think it's
like how do I spin this every time I
look in the mirror and all I see is like
the negative stuff okay Lisa I promise
myself and it's going to be hard and
it's going to be happy happy forming
every time I step in the mirror the
first things in my mind is gonna be damn
you look hot
all right
so now you are practicing a different
type of way of the Habit formation that
you may have of the hate you have for
yourself so that's going to be key is
acknowledging and noticing when you're
doing those things so that you can then
come up with a plan to do the opposite
or a plan to interrupt to disrupt that
idea disrupts the hate that you are
having for yourself
now another thing a lot of people have
said that I actually think is amazing is
maybe write down all the things that you
hate about yourself that you say to
yourself
now imagine you say that to your friend
well
what you can actually do while that can
like may give you like the sick feeling
of like oh God I would never say that to
my friend so actually this is a great
way to come up with the opposite put the
all the things on one side all the stuff
you say you hate about yourself on one
side put a line and then on the other
side put what you would say
instead if your friend thought like this
what words not what she oh no you've got
a lovely nose not that but if you could
give her a device what advice would you
give her or what words to change about
herself
because that's what's really hard it's
really hard to look at the inside of
what you're doing to yourself it's
really freaking hard guys so if it's
easier to put it on someone else and
then use it as a third person so you can
actually see the words that you're
saying to yourself that could be really
powerful and then once you've identified
the words that you're saying to yourself
then you have the other column that
allows you to flip it and change the
wording and now you've got a little mini
dictionary keep that in your pocket
don't be yourself up every time you slip
no big deal take it out go oh yep I was
supposed to say that all right thank you
and then repeat it habits habit habit
but you have to create the habit and in
order to create the Habit you have to
have a plan in place and so my plan is
let's say a little cheat sheet you pull
it out and you use different words
so that to me is how you start to
recognize when you hate yourself to
recognize it and then what to do when
you are in it now the self-love and then
the hate the the yin and the yang
I'm gonna be honest because I'm not
gonna [ __ ] you guys sometimes I find
it very very useful because I've changed
the language I use them with hate it's
the Improvement
and their Improvement and the reason why
I call it Improvement is because hates a
hard word but if I say the Improvement
side of me that side of me is the one
that's saying Lisa you're terrible in
front of the camera Lisa who the hell do
you think you are Lisa you're gonna go
on the camera with in Pink So if I take
the word hate and I use the word
Improvement now when that voice in my
head that is trying to be mean that is
trying to be cool they're trying to tell
me all the things of what I'm bad at and
what I'm not good at I now use the word
Improvement now that voice that is
telling me you're no good like you're
not good in front of the camera well I'm
gonna miss Improvement thank you for
telling me I'm not in front of the
camera oh I need to improve great how do
I improve so I'm using the negative
feedback in my head as actually a tool
to better myself which then makes me
love myself more because now I'm not
beating myself up because now I've gone
oh all this hate that you just had over
here the Improvement is actually helping
you get better so now it becomes like
this like we love relationship with
myself where I'm using the height as
fuel but again I'm changing the word hey
I'm just using it as fuel I'm using it
as a way to say what I have to do better
how can I improve
um what are the things I'm not good at
right now I use that negative voice as a
way to help me there and then you have
the self-love that also comes in and
that gives you the pat on the back but
also I'm also going to say I don't
necessarily want soft love all the time
I don't want to all be like at least
everything's okay just love yourself no
you're fine no I'm not I've got to
improve I want to get better I want to
improve I want to get stronger I want to
get better in front of the camera I want
to get better in the gym I want to be a
better wife I want to be a better friend
I want to be a better host so to me I
love the juxtaposition the ying and the
Yang of love and self-improvement step
number five is don't tie confidence to
self-image with Brendan burchard don't
tie confidence to image
don't tie your confidence
to image
don't tie confidence to image
okay now some of you this is super basic
right we'll go deep but this is a really
basic one and that is a lot of people
tie their confidence to what
they're to image like how do I look like
you know this is that old thing it's
like oh well if you're not in the
perfect body weight the perfect size
jeans or you don't have six pack abs or
you hate your hair that day or you know
something in terms of your image
is not what you want then what ends up
happening is you lessen your sense of
self and you feel like your confidence
is lowered and this is happening in not
just physical manifestations
manifestations for a lot of people like
well I don't like you know I don't like
my body Brendan so I'm lacking
confidence I'm like why is your
confidence tied to your body
huh
or they say well Brennan you know
I'm embarrassed by you know my website
it's not as nice as other people so I've
lost confidence in my dream I'm like why
is your confidence tied to your website
oh Brandon you know
we just got divorced and you know it's
embarrassing when I walk the dog because
I'm not with my husband anymore and I I
you know I know what the neighbors are
thinking so I just feel like I'm lacking
confidence I'm like why
is your confidence tied to what you look
like when you are walking a dog you know
there's all these things or or Brandon I
I don't know I'm so embarrassed my
Instagram thing is you know I only have
55 followers and it's so embarrassing
like why is your confidence tied to the
number of followers
what we do is we externalize our
confidence and it causes so much pain
we got to change this deal y'all you
listen that's okay when you're in high
school because you don't know better and
you're immature but everybody by the end
of high school had better learned that
confidence should not be tied to
external measures or the perception of
others based on our image and I know
where this is going to go with a lot of
you because I've been blessed to coach
so many people at high levels I know
some of you go no no Brennan you're
totally wrong on this one
because you know listen there was a time
when you know I was in terrible shape
and I looked terrible and then I took
control of my health Brendan and and I
and I I got better looking you know I
lost some of that weight and I I'm happy
in my body Brendan and I am more
confident because I am healthier I'm you
know lean and mean and trim and I feel
good about that I said oh well
um if you think about it psychologically
your confidence didn't come from the
fact that you are lean and mean now
like what I said confidence came from
that process
the confidence came from your
willingness to get in and do it your
belief and your ability to figure out
and the fact that you showed up and you
did it the progress through the struggle
gave you the confidence
the outcome which you're celebrating oh
well Brendan but I I've lost this weight
I'm you know I'm better here it is okay
that is what a high schooler does oh
this external thing died now I can be
confident you know I got an article on
the front page of the student newspaper
now I can be confident it's like we we
get these external Rewards or accolades
and we think it's the outcome that gives
us confidence but if that's your life
you'll never have the confidence that
you really really could have because
guess what
those external image things the Accolade
the award how you look in the mirror
those things are going to change
throughout the life
and you know it because guess what
you're now you're going to hit a certain
look and you're going to want a
different look or you're going to have a
certain award and want a different award
or a bigger award or a certain bank
account and want the next level of bank
account because those external things
are always moving if your confidence is
rooted in those external things moving
all the time you feel like this all the
time right a lot of your insecurities is
because you're tapping you're like
trying to glom on to all these external
things image right these external things
and I want these external things but
they're not solid
and because they're not solid and
they're always shifting you don't feel
solid and you feel like you're always
shifting and even though you've actually
achieved some amazing things you have
the image things you have the award
things you have the Accolade things you
have the successes you have a bigger
bank account than you used to
you still don't feel confident in self
why because you were attaching
confidence to that outer thing and how
it felt like in terms of image in the
moment
you didn't give yourself the appropriate
psychological credit and identity
as a striver who strived who knocked it
out who made it happen you didn't reward
the effort
instead you tried to celebrate the
outcome but because the outcomes are now
shifting and shaping and you want more
and more you always feel deficient and
deficient
because the outward the image I'm just
using that word image that image thing
the Accolade thing that success thing
it's moving so much you have to
understand this it's why I know people
who are literally 40s 50s like and they
still don't have confidence and I know
some of you are like but wait a second
Brendan well listen to this I I have a
client
she's the cover of Magazine's type of
person right Super Famous
um I'm working with her right now taking
her through chpc just started a couple
weeks ago with her and something really
fascinating has happened is she's
received all these Awards in her life
and she still doesn't have the
confidence
and I said well what other Awards do you
need to achieve and so and she actually
well I'd like to get this one now and
I'd like to get that one now and I like
to get this one I said but you already
got a trail of ten other ones over here
if those 10 other ones didn't give you
confidence why do you believe another
one with why listen listen very closely
my friends because I love you if that
last dollar increase in your bank
account didn't give you more confidence
please don't fool yourself in thinking
the next extra dollar in your bank
account is going to give you more
confidence
it's very important to understand right
off the bat
that the shifting of the external
the shifting of those things that we
want the shifting of the rewards of the
accolades of the dollars of the houses
of the cars because those will always
shift we'll always want a different one
a newer one a fresher one a better one
including in our body
then guess what
it's hard to ever feel fully competent
or confident to ever feel within like a
sense of goodness
you've got to start rewarding yourself
based on effort and not outcome and step
number six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is develop positive
body language with Marissa appear I saw
myself on television many years ago and
I noticed I was doing this throughout
the whole interview and I thought um
that's not a good look and I learned
when I was on TV to sit on my hands and
to speak quite slowly if you look at the
camera and you know I wasn't confident I
would say oh my God you are so confident
and I really wasn't do I looked at
people who were and I thought oh they
speak slowly they don't flap around they
may do that or that but they're very
composed they keep their shoulders up
they keep their stomach in they don't
sit like that so
you can do that whenever you're talking
to someone try to keep your chin up keep
your shoulders down and back speak
slowly don't speak Fast and Loud if
you've ever seen those movies like Mafia
moves you notice the head guy they
almost whisper and everyone has to kind
of listen to them they don't shout they
don't get all excited because powerful
people speak slowly they are very
commanding they command the stage they
have presence
and you can have it too by speaking
slowly
taking on the posture shoulders up and
back chin just so make eye contact when
you speed will look at them you have two
ears and one mouth for a reason to speak
and then listen listen to other people
make them feel interesting imagine if
everyone you met had a little sentence
tattooed on there for that said please
make me feel important
so when you meet people it isn't about
you saying yeah here I am and this is
what I do and I'm this and
what do you do tell me about you act as
if you're interested you know
it's what the Royal Family do they smile
they listen they do it hundreds of times
they're probably not interested in you
and the tomatoes you grow but they make
a point of acting like they are and
that's a great gift and you know I do
book signings will say oh my God you're
so nice you're so available I make a
point of making everyone feel
interesting smiling at everyone signing
their names saying who will you telling
me they're buying my book I owe them
that at least I don't go on another one
scribble scribble scribble there you are
I engage with people I make them feel
important thank you I don't ask them to
make me feel important it's their body
language posture don't do all this
ringing your hands fiddling with a
little hang now playing with your
jewelry fluffing your hair doing that
because you're saying I'm nervous
strength
is shown in Stillness
it will still you are the more strong
and powerful you appear
speak slowly
try to be still in your movements
try not to wave around and and help
yourself by believing in yourself
there are so many things you can do that
give you the posture of someone who
believed in themselves walk with
confidence
talk with confidence meet people's eye
level people make this classic mistake
someone says tell me about you and they
go well what I do is and and they try to
race her in case that person is bored
don't do that say well what I do is and
the reason I do it and why I love it so
much and take your time don't go into a
whole story but don't rush Who You Are
and what makes your heart sing if you
want a bored you'll find out and then
you can just say anyway enough about me
what about you but don't gavel through
it
when you're speaking to someone you'll
know if they're bored because their
shoulders will start to turn towards
their door their shoulders their knees
their hips and when you're bored you'll
notice that you do that you really want
to do that if you're suing someone who
might be going to employ you no matter
how bored you are keep your shoulders
your knees and your hips face towards
them keep that towards them and then it
says I'm interested in you I find you
interesting if you want to flirt do the
same thing keep focus and someone takes
the energy fluff off their shirt touch
them and even if it's not a romantic
thing study shows that waitresses who
touch their customers on the arm or
waiters and go thank you so much get
bigger tips
there was a test where people had to
stop in the street and say to someone
hey I'm lost could you tell me where to
go and that's the person did they
touched would you thank you and then it
just went up and then interviews went up
to them and you know the ones who got
touched remembered everything about the
person who touched them they weren't
attracted to them but the person that
touched them on the arm they could
remember what they looked like and what
they said
so touch is very important it's okay to
touch and we're not consistently and
obviously respect their boundaries you
touch their shoulder or their arm and if
you think they won't like it you don't
do it here's one final thing when we're
nervous our mouth gets dry we've all
seen people licking their lips because
they are nervous you may notice that
Court Lawyers drink water all their own
people giving evidence drink water when
you are nervous
your mouth gets dry and you lick your
lips when you're nervous you tend to
have your shoulders up around your ears
if you're nervous
push your shoulders down all the way
down and then
fill up your mouth with saliva Pump It
round your mouth I know it sounds
disgusting but who knows you're doing it
you didn't know I just did that
if you can make your mouth aware you
send a message to your mind that says
I'm really relaxed
guess what you do there every time you
kiss when you kiss
your mouth gets wet and your brain goes
wet mouth equals being relaxed doesn't
matter which way it comes
so fill up your mouth with saliva swirl
it around and your brain will think wet
mouth means you're relaxed if you're
nervous do that
drink water swirl it around I promise
you
it sends a message your mind that says
you are relaxed keep your shoulders down
it says you are relaxed keep your chin
up shoulders back posture good and it
says you are confident so you can trick
your mind into believing you're
confident and you're relaxed by the way
you hold yourself by the way you walk by
the way you talk by the volume of your
voice by the speed of your voice by your
hand movements by eye contact
and people who are successful do this
naturally
and you may have to do it unnaturally
who cares if you do it you know what
happens it starts being who you are and
what you do
and then it is who you are so it starts
by being what you do and then it becomes
who you are you'll find that if you keep
pushing your shoulders down filling up
your mouth with saliva holding yourself
straight making eye contact that
eventually you do it on autopilot
if you think that your thoughts have
something to do with your future just
from a theoretical standpoint that your
thoughts Create Your Destiny and you
think sixty to seventy thousand thoughts
in one day and 90 of those thoughts are
the same thoughts as the day before well
then your life isn't going to change
very much as long as you're thinking the
same way and those those same thoughts
lead to the same choices the same
choices lead to the same behaviors the
same behaviors create the exact same
experiences and we anticipate the same
feelings or emotions from those
experiences and those emotions are the
payoff that drive our very same thoughts
while our biology our neuroscircuitry
neurochemistry our hormones and even our
gene expression will be equal to how we
think how we act and how we feel and how
we think how we act and how we feel is
called our personality and our
personality creates our personal reality
that's it so the present personality
who's listening to this show has created
the present personal reality called
their life so if you can latch on to
this idea if you want to create a new
life a new personal reality you got to
change your personality which means you
better start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and changing it you
begin to become conscious of your
unconscious actions or habits or
behaviors and modify them and then we
have to begin to look at the emotions
that we live by every single day
that'll keep us connected to the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
our future so most people are trying to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain
that is the habit of ourselves it's a
we're 95 percent of the time running a
series of programs so then sitting and
doing the work we have to become
disentangled from those programs and so
the moment you decide to do something
differently or make a new choice but
most people don't want to face is that
discomfort and that that discomfort that
that uncertainty that lack of
predictability the that that that
unknown is what people are afraid of
because they'd rather live in guilt at
least they can predict who they're going
to be then take a chance and possibility
so when a person begins to understand in
this and you say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically
but when you step out into that unknown
into that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and is producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy then be in this this
conference so then at least then when
they return back to that familiar
feeling then they feel safe so they step
out in the unknown and the body starts
influencing the mind saying you can
start tomorrow you're too busy it's your
mother's fault you know it's your
culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then to meditate it means
to become familiar with so as you become
familiar with those thoughts you become
conscious of how you speak you become
aware of how you act you notice how
you're feeling the more conscious you
become of those unconscious programs the
less unconscious you'll go in your
waking day why because it's not enough
to just have a great meditation and get
up and get on the freeway and get in
traffic I'm getting stressed you just
return back to the old self again our
job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can get ready because something
different or unusual is going to begin
to happen in your life and it will come
as a coincidence or synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which
uh the community can change brain or
hard coherence they they know how to do
it it's not uh something that's that's
separate from them they've practiced it
enough times that they they now know how
to do it so what's the significance of
that well really simple in your life
if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological a
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work he can't tell me you had
a turbulent past or or that you're too
overweight or too underweight or too out
of shape or you can't even tell me that
you've never meditated before in fact
some of our greatest
Gans or people who just have never
meditated before that they're not trying
to do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 in not sixty percent
and when we do a week-long event we got
a thousand people or 1500 people and
they are all in and that when they start
getting Beyond themselves that first day
or second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting you
don't have to necessarily have done
anything wrong for things to get
completely out of control
it's a terrifying Doctrine but it's not
a hopeless Doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the pathway
forward is to adopt a mode of being that
has some nobility so that you can
tolerate yourself and perhaps even have
some respect for yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned is by well certainly by the
avoidance of Deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually Rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is
there well too as far as I'm concerned
and some of this is from Clinical
experience you know if you take people
and I've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over decades long periods what they
could be like if they were who they were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something I mean you can think
about this yourselves I often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying watching things on YouTube that
not only do you not want to watch that
you don't even care about that make you
feel horrible about watching after
you're done that's probably four hours
right there you know you think well
that's 20 25 hours a week it's 100 hours
a month that's two and a half full work
weeks it's half a year of work weeks per
year and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting
fifty thousand dollars a year is a way
bigger catastrophe than it would be for
me to waste it because I'm not going to
last nearly as long and so if your life
isn't everything it could be you could
ask yourself well what would happen if
you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment both of which are are are our
major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt it isn't merely that your
fate depends on whether or not you get
your act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to Peak
at about 9 billion by the way and then
it'll decline rapidly but seven billion
people in the world and who are you
you're just one little dust moat among
that seven billion and so it really
doesn't matter what you do or don't do
but that's simply not the case it's the
wrong model because you're at the center
of a network you're a node in a network
of course that's even more true now that
we have social media you'll you'll know
a thousand people at least over the
course of your life and they'll know a
thousand people each and that puts you
one person away from a million and two
persons away from a billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but I mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice I can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
now when you say well nihilists suffered
dreadfully because there's no meaning in
their life and they still suffer yeah
but the advantage is they have no
responsibility
so that's the payoff and I actually
think that's the motivation say well I
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is a meaningless suffering
but you can always whine about that and
people will feel sorry for you and you
have the option of taking the pathway of
the Martyr so that's a pretty good deal
All Things Considered especially when
they are when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well with
sojournitzen figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends because that's
what happened in the 20th century you
wanted to be a professional baseball
player right yeah but then you got an
injury idea similar to me so you never
made it to the big leagues or did you
play minor league I did yeah and I
played division one college baseball too
yeah I like every guy like you and I
talked about this last time it's always
our injuries that ended our careers I
probably it probably put me into a
premature place where I was going
anyways you aren't going to be in The
Bigs for I wasn't I played enough
baseball with guys who ended up in the
big leagues to know my limitations yeah
so like anything in life things happen
for you not to you that injury happened
for me certainly didn't seem like it at
the time but it got me out of that and
into something like what we're talking
about now that completely changed my
life so yeah but yeah I want to be an
athlete for sure all my life all your
life that was my mask and then when it
exactly exactly and then when it ended
your identity was like who am I right
yes lost yeah like a lot you and I were
just talking this before we went on yeah
you know our professional athlete
friends were there rare changes I went
into a like anybody like whatever your
dream is when the first one ends it
doesn't happen whether that be a
relationship it could be your marriage
it ends it was a dream right or a
business venture or a sport I went into
a pretty good depression and uh and how
old were you at the time
21-22 and I ended up you know it's
because people always see the after like
the house or whatever houses or whatever
the material things are but I ended up
bad man I ended up depressed I ended up
moving back at home with my parents I
was living in the city I remember I was
living in this sleeping in the same bed
I grew up in with the same teddy bear
the same posters I was like going back
in time like six years on back where I
was totally unemployed and uh couldn't
find work didn't have the motivation to
get up and find a job just sort of
eating out of their fridge and laying
around all day so so that's where I was
many many years ago after baseball and
when you realize things in your life
happen for you truly especially in
hindsight everybody knows it in
hindsight right if you look back at any
disaster tragedy most people look back
five ten years later that happened for
me that was actually a good thing and so
I was unemployed I couldn't find a job
and my old man my dad was the best dad
role model he could ever have in your
life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me was more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
it's right down the street in San Dimas
you're going to be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're gonna get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 A.M
ask for Tim so I walked out I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter
my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there
I said I'm at mylette I'm here for the
job you're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah and I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know it's the last name and
they're like so you showed up for a job
that you don't know what it is and you
don't know who it is it's hiring you I'm
like here's what I know he's an
alcoholic I'm like oh damn yeah we know
that too and so they bring me to the guy
and he says uh you're hired let's go
like literally shakes my hand and you're
hired and he introduces me to these
eight boys that were my boys they were
seven eight and nine years old and
basically I lived with these boys these
precious boys and we ended up adding a
few more my boys were all Wards of the
Court they were all molested by family
where parents were in prison and so they
had no family and so my whole life
changed all of a sudden these became on
this 22 year old guy these guys become
my sons wow and I did holidays with them
I did birthdays with them I lived with
them literally in a home or like
McKinley is a massive campus full of
children that have been displaced from
their homes that live in individual like
Cottages like a foster care facility
massive though really yep all boys
it's in San Dimas here and wow it just
altered my life man because I I'd been
an athlete had a huge ego had that mask
I wanted to compete I wanted to win I
wanted attention I wanted recognition
first time literally in my life I went
well I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they're just like man love me believe in
me you know care about me and I had
those eyes because I grew up in an
alcoholic family and my whole life
changed I just went wow I love I
actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives I didn't know
that because everything was you're great
you're great you know what it is when
you're an athlete right everything's
about you you're amazing free dinners
free this you're a stud all of a sudden
I was in a stud and all of a sudden it
wasn't about me it was about these 10
boys that ended up being 10 of them and
it just altered my life man and so after
that I ran into the financial business
that I ended up in but I would have
completely flunked out of that Financial
business had I not been with my boys for
those years and I was there for two
years two years yeah man like eight
hours a day type of thing or sometimes
more sometimes 16 18. I I think about
I'm not kidding you I think about my
boys and my experience there two of them
are still very close with me uh every
day there's a moment where I reflect on
that it altered me completely like what
I wanted to do I always wanted to be
famous and Rich and successful and now I
just wanted to serve yeah I wanted to
help the little did I find out I could
get rich and famous and all that other
stuff I thought I wanted through serving
people see this line
that's called The Terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it and on the other
side of the terror barrier is something
we call Freedom
and you know
very few people get through that Terror
barrier it's rather sad freedom is
available to everyone there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to
live
see
why don't they
why don't they
they don't know and they don't even know
they don't know
now I'm going to show you why people
experience buyer's remorse when they buy
something they really want and then they
back away or they go to move and they
don't they go to change jobs and they
don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why fear causes them to stay where
they are
here's the individual the X represents
the unknown factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we have the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the Paradigm
now here's an important point the
Paradigm controls the vibration of this
thing we call our body our body is a
molecular instrument that's really what
it is it's a mass of molecules and a
very high speed of vibration
the vibration of the body is in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts that harmonize with
the vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting X tape
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
Paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison to walk out into
Freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage now let's go ahead here's the
same person
X-Type conditioning X-Type vibration the
power is flowing into them and for some
strange reason from Left Field above
bone in comes a y-type idea what is the
y-type idea the y-type idea represents
anything that you might want to do that
you're not doing
it might be moved to another city change
jobs
sell the house buy the phone
whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date ask the
guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea but as long as the Y idea is just
in the conscious mind it's just going to
be an intellectual exercise it's never
going to happen
so how do we make it happen well that's
when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power Flows In
and what do they do they got the y-type
idea now for some strange reason they
know that they've got to get emotionally
involved that they're going to act on
that idea they don't understand what's
going to happen but clearly understand
this your central nervous system is the
most complex electrical system in the
universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling it would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mine that's when
all hell breaks loose because the body
moves in to an extra XY vibration it's
not in the X vibration not the one that
we're comfortable with may not like the
results but we're comfortable no on a
conscious level everything's going crazy
on a conscious level we experience doubt
that doubt turns into an emotion called
fear and that fear is expressed through
the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that Terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like at least they're
comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that Terror
barrier see the terror barrier is going
Beyond where you're at going to a new
level I'm going to tell you something
when I set a goal if if it doesn't scare
and excite me at the same time I know
I'm going in the wrong direction now I
also understand that my Paradigm is
going to try and get me to bounce back
to where I was it doesn't want me to
move ahead
I don't want to live there
I used to live there for the first 26
years of my life and for the last 50
I've had a phenomenal life and it just
keeps getting better and I want you to
do the same thing understand what I've
just said I'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the Y
idea that moved their body into a
different vibration on a conscious level
their experiencing some crazy stuff they
start to dump their ability and they'll
never be able to pay for it they should
experience fear the fear expresses
itself as anxiety
and bang you bounce off that Terror
barrier and you're right back
oh I might not be earning much hair but
I know what it is
I I would love to move there but I'm
comfortable here I think I'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't you know what to do say I'm gonna
get rid of all that I understand it's
there but I don't want any part of it
and I'm going to go crashing right
through that Terror barrier now does
that get rid of the X energy no that's
energy
is still there you see but at least
you're over into Freedom you made the
move you did it and if you continue to
feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that y idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know where you're living
in Freedom you're living where you want
to live
buyer's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that and if you don't learn to go
through the terror barrier I'm going to
tell you something you're going to stay
right where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell say
so true
they cave you fear to enter holds a
treasure you seek I know you all have
big goals Big Dreams big aspirations
just like I do you've got Ambitions to
become an amazing person to build your
career to create contribute to give to
be an awesome human being but all of
that is impossible without great habits
set up if you don't have routine and
structure set up in a way that will keep
you on track then you'll you'll fall off
and and having new goals without new
habits is kind of like you know having a
new car without wheels you know the
habits are the wheels they're the things
that make you able to achieve the goals
so you got to have good habits but the
challenge for most people isn't that
knowledge I mean you know you need to
have good habits it's you can't keep the
Habit going right have you ever started
it the new year you're going to get
healthier and you start that habit of
working out on a more regular basis and
then it goes away or you say you know
I'm going to be more kind and more
patient and more awesome to my partner
my love her and you start being nice for
two or three days and then on the fourth
day you're a jerk you know and you're
like why what happened I said I was
gonna be nicer it's that you didn't set
up the most important thing you needed
to maintain a habit so what's the
biggest secret I've learned in almost 20
years in this field it's so simple but
most people don't have it it's called
trigger moments
you have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision in your journal or set up on
a vision board that you look at once in
a while but in day-to-day life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you'd obviously
become better well that makes sense well
let's use that idea let's use that idea
by setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this can be so basic you're going
to laugh and then also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with this let's have a
goal in mind let's say you want to
become more present and calm throughout
the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm going to be more present and
calm you can meditate in the morning say
today don't be more present and calm and
you're you could you could start out
with good intentions but those fall
apart without a trigger moment set up
throughout the day to remind you that so
what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label that said
close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
pm and again it happens at 8pm what's
gonna happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
it you can't do it once a day you have
to have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I've
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right at least could be as simple
as let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water put
your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words
so what words would you love to have
describe you as a person that you would
be happy if that was how people
described you what would those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life I teach Executives to do this as
well I have them have a door frame
trigger when they walk into their office
in the morning as soon as they walk
through that door frame they have boom
three words go through their mind about
how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
every time they walk into a meeting into
the conference room when they walk
through the doors of the conference room
they have another three words that
trigger off for them and it just reminds
them how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people think they have
to completely change their life what
would change your life completely is
setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things self-confidence
self-love self-respect it all comes from
deciding to do something difficult
here's what happens when when something
hard comes up and you find a reason why
you can't do it
too hard it's too difficult it's too
scary
most people will let you off the hook
the people around you will say yeah yeah
that's way too hard I mean the fact you
even thought about it was crazy
you let yourself off the hook
but then you realize
you know like that's the worst feeling
in the world that you could have done
something
but then you came up with an excuse as
to why you can't
and that will eat you up
and even if the world lets you off the
hook
recognize that they have lower standards
than you
recognize that the people who are giving
you that advice and patting on the back
and saying it's okay you don't need to
do it they don't like their life either
they're stuck they're trapped
they're not pushing hard they're not
being aggressive for their goals they're
not tough either
and we're reinforcing that Comfort Loop
every day comfort you versus growth you
are in a fight there's a war going on
inside you comfort you versus growth you
comfort Evan birth is growth Evan every
day there's a fight there's a battle
there's a war going on and you need to
decide who's gonna win the fight
it's a daily thing and the more growth
you wins against comfort you the more
you start to grow the more you start to
hit your goals the more you start to
have an impact the more you start to
love yourself
[Music]
because again even if the world would
let you off the hook
you know it's just an excuse
I think most people think of it as a
giant step that you have to take to
build that self-confidence it's not I
think it's much more about the daily
battles with yourself that then builds
up to Major things just like you don't
go to the gym and lift 400 pounds you
start by lifting five pounds or ten
pounds or 20 pounds or 40 pounds
whatever it is that's how you start to
build the muscle it's much more about
the Daily building of the muscle to show
yourself who you are much more than the
one-off heroic moments here's an example
so uh yesterday we had an insane
snowstorm here in Toronto I don't know
if we can it's kind of blurry can't see
we had like you see some here behind me
it's like look at see that mountain of
snow behind me we had an insane
snowstorm we had probably the worst
snowstorm in Toronto Canada in the
decade I have not seen this much snow in
a crazy amount of time and so I'm going
for a walk
uh rocking and rucking is where you
carry a backpack so I'm carrying a
backpack of 20 pounds
as I'm walking doing my normal walk and
it's it's crazy outside normally the
rucking alone is hard enough and I just
increased the weight in the backpack now
I there's no path to wacon and this
morning I was walking through an area
and there was Zero path the snow is up
to my knees and I need to get through
so what's what are my options well I
could I could complain and turn around
right like I could look out the window
and say ah so much snow I'm not gonna do
that I'll do it when there's less snow
you know and then the next day there's
less snow there's still snow in the next
it's still snow and then all of a sudden
you just gave up on the Habit right like
you let yourself off the hook to say
I'll do it tomorrow and then and then
you never do it and then the habit's
gone and that's what you're teaching
yourself this is why it leads to
Identity this is why it leads to
negative self-worth and negative
self-confidence because the next time
you come up with an idea you've already
reinforced the training you're training
yourself that when you come up with an
idea you don't do the thing when you say
you're gonna do it and you're gonna
start tomorrow and then you don't the
next time you come up with an idea guess
what you you've already reinforced the
pattern I don't follow through I'm not
going to do that I'm excited today but
tomorrow I won't follow through
so there's a snow is up to my knees
right up to my knees and I'm six one so
it's it's some serious snow like I gotta
walk through not quite that that's
that's probably taller than me uh I
don't have to walk through that much but
but up to my knees
I'm looking at it and I've got to go I
don't know
100 meters
through this thing
and initially my thought was oh man why
is there no path why is nobody shoveled
this why is nobody still Blowfish like I
gotta get over there I got a backpack on
I'm rocking I'm sweating like crazy I'm
already exhausted now I gotta go through
this
this is when we need to catch ourselves
right everybody would have let me off
the hook
and another me would have let me off the
hook right Comfort Evan would have let
growth happen off the hook so it's okay
go back home
or go the long way around where there's
a path don't go through that snoped your
knees
and as soon as I caught it
now what
most of the time you won't catch it most
of the time you'll just do
you'll do the automatic thing and
usually the automatic thing is is the
comfort thing so usually play small by
default usually you you'll look outside
and see the snow and not go just by
default not even catching the the
conversation with yourself
but when you catch it
this is a really important moment what
do you do do you do the difficult thing
or do the comfort thing
because when you catch it and you make a
conscious choice this is how we start to
either change our Identity or reinforce
our identity
so I looked at it I caught it and said
I'm going through let's go you know I
caught the negative thinking I caught
the Comfort Evan coming over walk around
go home nope not happening we're going
through we are going through we're gonna
make it through
and it was rough
yeah I'm walking through I'm freezing uh
I'm taking one kind of giant step at a
time snow is getting all through my
boots all down my legs I I almost slip
and fall I have a coffee that I that I
picked up uh it's dripping all over the
place
and in my head as I'm going through it
it's like this is the best
let's go let's go Evan you got this man
let's go
you do difficult things that's the thing
on repeat in my head
combined with that
I'm also telling myself that you know
what not only am I doing this difficult
thing for me I'm also creating the path
for other people that the next person
who comes up against this 100 meters or
so that now they will have not an easy
time but an easier time of crossing the
same path
so they can get across
so it's going to service
if you're ever having a hard time
getting yourself to do something
it's one you do difficult things remind
yourself and two default the service
that it's not just about you it's for
other people now that may not even be
true
maybe nobody ever comes across that path
maybe I didn't make it easier for the
next person maybe somebody comes five
minutes after me and snow blows the
whole thing and so there was Zero
service
it doesn't matter it's the story that
I'm telling myself that it will serve
other people that will get you to then
do the difficult thing
so in order to make it happen
there's two triggers that I use one is
language so scary difficult or hard if
you say those things if you feel those
things if you text those things if you
write those things if you're talking to
yourself and you catch those things then
you have to do it you can no longer
accept scary difficult or hard as
reasons for you not to do the thing
because your great life is on the other
side of scary difficult heart everything
you want the business you want the
relationships you want the help that you
want everything everything your great
life if you wrote down a list of
everything you want out of life
everything on that list comes on the
other side of you doing scary difficult
and hard things
growth you that's growth you fighting
comfort you
so when you catch yourself sane speaking
writing thinking scary difficult to
heart that's a that's a trigger it
should be a trigger it's a trigger for
me it should be a trigger for you to go
and do it do it go walk through the
giant snow and you might be thinking
well how does that help me with my
business it's just walking through snow
and I'm going to be cold and have snow
in my boots how does that help me
it's an identity thing
because as soon as you start to teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who follows through on those scary
difficult hard things
then the next time that shows up
anywhere in your life in your business
and your relationships and your health
anything that actually helps you
accomplish your goals you're going to be
ready to show up for it you're going to
be more likely to actually do the thing
because you've been training and
conditioning yourself to do the thing
that's why walking through 100 meters of
snow matters
so the first is scary difficult hard
those are verbal cues or thought cues
the second is the boom boom boom test
where your heart is beating quickly it's
like when your heart is going crazy like
that
it's usually because you should be doing
something you're afraid right now don't
again go don't go don't go standing on
the highway uh because it's scary and it
makes your heart race right don't be
stupid but most of the things that
you're afraid of
aren't actually things that are going to
be life-threatening
right they're not there usually it's
other people's opinions usually you're
afraid of not failing but somebody
watching you fail right you're gonna
fail at something who's gonna see you
that's what we're actually afraid of and
that cannot be a good enough reason it
can't not anymore you're afraid of
losing in front of somebody if you're
afraid of other people's opinions if you
are living your life based off of the
expectations and Judgment of other
people you will never do anything great
you will never live your great life
because somebody always has a plan for
what you should be doing with your life
you will never please everybody it's not
possible
you have to start to learn to please
yourself and it's not doing something
just to show off and just to prove
somebody wrong I'm not a big fan of
tapping into that energy the reason to
do something is not to prove somebody
wrong and make somebody else look stupid
the reason to do something is because
that's who you are and that's what you
want to do
and so learning to do difficult things
teaching yourself step by step grip by
Brick one snow uh storm at a time
teaching yourself that
will change your life
you deserve a better life you deserve a
great life
when that comes on the other side of you
doing the things that are scary
difficult and
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you're
introverted and want to become confident
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there when are the
moments that you must put the mask of
assertiveness if you're shy you don't
have to necessarily become an unshy
person you have to find out the ability
in the moments that you can put the mask
of assertiveness on